good evening everyone and welcome good
evening we have one more panelist who is
finishing up another engagement in the
building and will be here shortly but we
thought we'd go ahead and get started
okay Kennedy I'm the administrator of
the Pulitzer Prizes and I'm delighted to
welcome you to the annual Pulitzer Prize
seminar which again this year features
three journalists whose important
impactful work epitomizes the best in
American journalism their work comes at
a critical time when celebrating
extraordinary journalism is more
important than ever
but celebrating the stories and images
that move us and bring about change is
not enough now more than ever we must
use we I'm sorry now more than ever we
must also defend this kind of journalism
against relentless threats to freedom of
the press the noble profession we
believe in some is Pulitzer winners some
preparing to lead the next generation of
news gatherers and storytellers is worth
fighting for it is not called the Fourth
Estate for nothing our journalism is a
vital part of American democracy and we
must not allow anyone to lead us to
believe there anything about it is fake
instead we must be undeterred in our
mission to more forcefully support those
who report and disseminate vital
information without fear or favor it is
the kind of work that these journalists
are about it's what they do boldly and
powerfully and better than just about
anybody you will hear more about their
BIOS and bodies of work in a moment but
I want to welcome all of you and I want
to thank Sarah Eric and Daniel will be
joining us soon for taking the time to
be a part of this most important
discussion
so I hope you all will be engaged ask
them a lot of terrific questions and I'm
looking forward to hearing much more
about the groundbreaking work that each
of them produced thank you good evening
everyone
as you know I'm Sheila Coronel I'm Dean
of Academic Affairs I have the pleasure
of hosting this seminar I've been doing
this for the last five years I think and
it's always wonderful to be celebrating
great work so what we'll do here let me
just explain to you how we do this I
would present each of the prize-winning
work we will be featuring here tonight I
will introduce the work and the authors
I will ask the the Award winner to
answer a few questions and then open up
to questions from you you and then we
move on to the next award winner and so
on at the end of when all three have
been presented you will also have a
chance to ask more questions so if I
don't get to call you after each award
winner was presented you'll have a
chance at the end I promise is that is
that a good deal so let me also warn you
that this is being live-streamed so be
careful what what you say so let me
start here by formally opened this
year's Pulitzer Prize seminar the first
work I'd like to produce I'd like to
introduce is the winner of the gold
medal Pulitzer gold medal is awarded
every year for public service and it's a
story about the something most of you
are familiar with already now that
you're in the sixth week of your
reporting class the NYPD in in the 1970s
a nuisance abatement law was created to
combat the sex industry in Times Square
nuisance abatement is a policing
technique it allows the police to shut
down places or people from their homes
they believe these are being used for
drugs and other illegal activities today
in New York City's crime rate is is at a
historic low but as Sarah Riley the
winner of the 2017 put its reward for
public service has found the NYPD fires
more than 1,000 nuisance and basement
cases a year nearly half of them against
tenants of public or low-cost housing in
a series of articles for ProPublica and
the Newark Daily News
Sarah reported that the law has been
used to kick people out of their homes
even if they haven't been found guilty
of any crime jameelah else Abbas who you
will find in the photo at the top left
is a 43 year old mother of five she was
one such victim her family comes from
Nigeria and they are devotees of the
ephah religion she offers fine white
powder which which we'll see they're
made of crushed egg shells to the ephah
deity that's also in the photo top right
when police marched into her home they
confiscated large amounts of the powder
and said it was cocaine Jamila and her
son spent a week in Rikers and were
eventually exonerated with the NYPD
continued to pursue her and two of her
sons who had previously been arrested on
drug possession charges
the police filed a nuisance abatement
case against Jamila and she would have
been kicked out of her apartment
had she not reached a settlement with
the NYPD Sarah Reilly first reported in
this practice in 2014 while reading a
lawsuit that mentioned the city tried to
evict someone based on charges that had
already been dismissed but whether this
practice was systemic or normally had
never been quantified Sarah was then an
editor and reporter for the New York
Daily News she is now with the nonprofit
news site tracer which you haven't which
happens if you haven't seen it you
should check it out it provides some of
the best reporting on guns in America
one of Sarah's areas of expertise is
broken windows policing
it's a controversial crime-fighting
philosophy that says penalizing people
for minor crime for minor crimes like
broken windows creates an atmosphere of
law and order and helps prevent more
serious offenses Sara knew she needed to
show it what that what had happened to
Jamila Elsa vos and her and her sons and
the many others she interviewed for the
story was part of a pattern of police
abuse but she also knew that it could
take years and possibly litigation to
get the NYPD to release data or nuisance
abatement cases as you know the NYPD is
one of the most secretive police
agencies in the country so Sara had to
gather the data herself she reviewed
over a thousand cases of nuisance
abatement actions and found that the
police had asked her thousands of
hundreds of people from their homes and
businesses
she found that most of the victims were
people of color in some of the city's
poorest neighborhoods Sarah scraped
index numbers for nuisance abatement
cases fired from 2013 to 2014 and put
the details about the cases into a
spreadsheet
she created multiple databases and
cross-reference the names of those
driven out of their homes with the
outcomes of the criminal charges against
them she found 173 cases of people who
gave up their leases or banned from
homes but were not convicted of any
crime for a ban from their homes even if
they had not been convicted 44 these
faced no criminal prosecution at all one
example is Kwan Verdi you see him in
these photos he's a recovering drug
addict who pleaded guilty to drug
possession after the police turned up a
bag of crack during a search of his
parents apartment in Jamaica Queens
police claimed values using his parents
home to sell crack he insisted he would
never sell drugs from his family home
where multiple generations share four
bedrooms but in order to protect his
family from losing their home Valle
agreed never to sleep there again he's
now barred from living at
for the rest of his life and he sleeps
at the homeless shelter on the Bowery
all together Sara and her team
identified the race of 215 of the 297
people who were barred from their homes
in nuisance abatement battles only five
are white they found that the toll of
nuisance abatement actions fell almost
exclusively on minorities 90% of the
homes subjected to such actions were in
minority communities the findings
shocked even veteran city politicians
many said they were unaware police were
targeting their homes or that the newest
ins abatement law granted the police
such extraordinary powers the series
prompted immediate reform efforts 13
bills were passed to add protections for
the accused the state court
administrator issued a lengthy notice
advising judges on best practices and
health training on the law and the NYPD
and the law department immediately began
a review of their cases have since made
changes for uncovering widespread abuse
of eviction rules by the police Sara
Riley was awarded the Pulitzer Prizes
highest honor the Public Service Award
welcome Sara thank you
sorry this was an amazing piece of work
and you walk us through you know what
you needed to do to get this work done
you know were you working with the team
or you're doing it largely with yourself
this is a collaboration between
ProPublica and the New York Daily News
can you tell us you know how that how
that worked
sure so I I did start working on the
story kind of chipping away at it here
and there when I had the time I think in
early 2014 and ended up teaming up with
ProPublica and mid-2015 because it would
have come out in 2016 so you know when I
first started on and I was working as a
projects editor and also doing some
reporting and I was working on a project
about police misconduct lawsuits with a
team of reporters and just kind of going
through the stacks of lawsuits came
across the one that you had mentioned in
your introduction that that said it was
a wrongful arrest case and a woman said
that the NYPD or the city rather had
filed an eviction on her you know based
on these charges I have been long since
dismissed so you know I think you know
at the outset even you know starting out
I knew that I wanted to create some sort
of you know database of cases to show
that you know just to even just to do
kind of like a test run to see if I did
a hundred cases what percentage of those
you know cases would someone have been
evicted from their home based on charges
that they were exonerated from in
criminal court in terms of you know what
it ultimately took to put the story
together I do think that one of the
strengths of the story is that it
involved you know data analysis and then
you know of course you know you know
based on the information that that we
entered into multiple spreadsheets the
ProPublica when when I teamed up with
them provided three researchers that
helped me do that manual entry and it
involved going through
thousands of thousands of pages of legal
documents and actually 15 different
courts because each borough in the city
has its own court system so we had to
pull records from the civil Supreme
Court which is where the nuisance
abatement actions were filed but then
also from the lower Criminal Court and
the Supreme Criminal Court because
criminal cases could be heard in either
one and and only two of those cases
courts rather have all of the records
online so that was certainly very
labor-intensive and you know when I
started out I had you know but my you
know initial question was just whether
it was systemic or an anomaly for these
civil cases to be based on criminal
charges that have been thrown out but
then you know as I started you know
going through the cases and doing some
of you know reporting I just noticed all
of these other things I initially wasn't
even aware that the law gave the NYPD
the authority to you know sweep down
without notice and and serve people with
an order that immediately closed down
their business or home before they'd
even gotten a chance to appear in court
to defend themselves that wasn't
something I really learned about until
you know sort of deeper into my
reporting so so the I think that the the
data the data entry and the data
analysis was a very important component
of it but I also think that the
extensive Street reporting field
reporting that I did was very important
we none of the people that were in the
series were people who were you know
passed on to me from a lawyer or an
advocate they were all people that you
know we found by going out into the
field and just knocking on doors
actually I mapped the cases because we
tracked the address and I geo coded the
addresses and then I just you know from
the map of my phone went to different
neighborhoods rather and and knocked on
doors and then I also did a lot of you
know course interviews with you know
officials and and went through
historical archives I think that the
history of the law is really
and so so yeah I mean it was I think
that sort of all the elements of
reporting kind of tied together the data
the shoe-leather reporting and then sort
of the more traditional investigative
reporting with the you know documents
and archives I went to the city
municipal archive Center and pulled like
Circuit Court cases no I actually looked
through the archives all the archives
about the nuisance abatement law so I
actually like pulled the microfiche from
the City Council records and you know
look through records on the law back to
the 70s so how much cooperation in codes
did you get from the NYPD while doing
this story not very much
they they did grant me two hour-long
sit-down interviews the first interview
I actually i quantify did at one point
I'd have to look back at the emails but
I think for about eight months I
followed up with him on that one sending
them emails calling sometimes I would
corner people from the press office of
the law department at events and then
finally they relented and and they did
sit down with me for an hour and I
talked with them about my findings at
that point and it was all on the record
which I think really added to this story
and then I did sort of a second analysis
you know after a party with ProPublica
where I had added of a bunch of
different factors into the into the
database you know that we were building
and and so for about five months there I
had to pass them for another interview
and and they gave another hour-long
interview but aside from that they
pretty much didn't answer any of my
follow-up questions even you know my
editor my editor chief at one point even
got involved so let's let's talk about
interviewing because this is something I
know our students are grappling with at
the moment you just knocked on people's
doors yeah and then and then what you
know it's funny because I get asked that
question a lot
even when I'm going through
the methodology for my data analysis I
find that a lot of times students just
want to know how to talk to people um so
I have a couple tips that I always give
I you know I did used to go door-to-door
for a while as a community organizer and
I actually use a lot of the same
techniques that I used back then you
know going door to door and talk any
people first and foremost
I always make good eye contact if you're
ever having trouble making eye contact
with somebody whether it be a really
intimidating city official or or just
you know someone at the door you can
just look right here and it makes it
look like you're giving an excellent eye
contact and I I just sort of naturally
extend my hand and shake people's hands
and I think it just depends on whether
it's natural for you but I I think that
the that you know shaking the hand and
making eye contact just sort of makes a
personal connection and shows respect
you know so that's just sort of things
that I always do I I always dress like
I'm going to work I think that's
important a lot of reporters will say
that you know I like to you know look
professionally and I think that that
kind of makes people you know feel like
they're more comfortable opening up to
sometimes you know again it's what works
for you and then with this case in this
series in particular you know I actually
almost have everybody that we approached
talked to us I should mention too that I
had a photographer with me a lot of the
time who is fluent in Spanish which
really helped in certain communities
like East Harlem and parts of the Bronx
I would not my Spanish is not very good
so so that was really important that he
was with me Edmund Torres is fantastic
photographer but so I had mentioned that
I use this free website called batch geo
where you can put a spreadsheet into a
map and so basically I had the
spreadsheet of all the cases including
notes on the cases and I did I
you know I always try and sort of know
stuff before I go and talk to people you
know everyone has their own technique
but a lot of times I'll sort of you know
try and get people invested in the story
that I'm working on and maybe you know
drop some you know details so because I
had that app well it's not an app but
like the spreadsheet sort of on a map I
was able to look at the case details
before every door every home or every
business that I went up to so you know
it makes it a little bit easier to
engage people in conversation when
you're asking them sort of you know sort
of specific questions and I don't ever
some other sort of tricks as I don't
ever ask people like will you talk to me
I just start talking to them and even as
I say no I'll just sort of you know
still sort of approach it like a
conversation and you just find that
people will get stuck sometimes with
their foot in the door for like you know
twenty thirty minutes talking to you and
and also sometimes like you know when I
first start talking out kind of like now
in my head a little bit and you find
that people will like mirror your body
language so I think body language is
important and another thing is I never
if I'm ever feeling like frustrated I
just take a break because I think that
it's really important to to feel like
people are going to talk to you and if
you sort of have negative feeling people
can sense that in your and your demeanor
or your eye contact and they're gonna
maybe be less likely to be open so those
are my tips for field reporting can you
walk us through the first two minutes of
when you knock on the door and then the
door opens what do you say hmm now I
feel like I'm giving like a like a rap
session or movie Scott um so I just a
knock on the door hi are you jameelah
another thing always helps is if you
kind of like know already know the
people's names before you go you go to
the door um so I'll be like hi are you
mrs. Shabazz hi it's nice to meet you
my name is Sarah Riley I'm a reporter
with the New York Daily News a name a
lot of people recognize I'm working on a
story right now about the NYPD's use of
fiction laws to push people out of their
homes and I've been going through cases
and I came across one that mentions your
house um I can see here you know from
the records that I looked at that looks
like the NYPD had filed a what's called
nuisance abatement action against your
home in September 2011 I hope I'm
remembering the details correctly do you
remember that and like yeah I remember
that yeah so yeah I just wanted to hear
more about it you know it said in the
court filings that there that the NYPD
was claiming that they found these forty
five cups of you know cocaine but it
turned out to be
eggshell powder that was actually in the
filings and usually from there the
conversation just goes yeah thank you I
hope I hope you found that useful I see
I see people nodding not audience one
last question before I turn it over to
our students how did the New York Daily
News in this time when news
organizations are heavily strapped for
resources how and why did you give that
give you like the time to work on this
story that took more than a year or
nearly two years yeah yeah I mean like I
said I worked on a sort of chipped away
at it for a long time on my own and then
broke off and work on it exclusively
with ProPublica for maybe like seven or
eight months so you know I think it's
actually a good question it is always
tough to get the time and the resources
to do a long-term investigation it
definitely didn't just come out of
nowhere I think that's important for
aspiring investigative journalists to
remember you know just sort keep in mind
as you're entering your career you know
I had done a lot of other projects
you know some of them much you know
quicker turnaround or all of them I've
never done anything that long-term
before but you know much quicker
turnaround and you know actually when I
when I started at the Daily News I was
the the courts editor so but I wanted to
go back to doing investigations which is
what I have been doing before so
initially when I started doing projects
and data projects I did it mostly on my
own time you know 11:00 12:00 at night I
would be at the office and just kind of
showing them that this is what they want
actually wanted me to do they didn't
want me on the desk they wanted me doing
investigations and I think that's really
important to remember because a lot of
times you know especially just getting
out of school you're not necessarily
gonna get the job that you want right
off the bat you're gonna have to show
your employer that they want you in the
job that you want to do and so I was
just doing the work that I wanted to do
when I when I had the opportunity and so
eventually I would get a day here a day
there are two days here five days there
you know sometimes a week but not often
to do you know other projects like and
you know broken windows police killings
you know turnstile jumping a lot of
stuff that resulted in changes in laws
and you know got awards and stuff like
that so it was building on top of all of
that that they then gave me this time
they just they just trusted me because I
you know I'd always followed through
came through with what you know I I said
that I was going to do all right your
turn to ask questions yes at the back
please do we have microphones oh yes the
other microphone are you oh there's a
microphone it's very yeah you have to
come all the way up here so that the
live stream can see you I guess
yes sir hi um so my question is you just
talked about the incident with Jimmy how
well things went great she did stand by
the door and listen to you but what
happens if someone just shuts the door
what's your plan B so if it's someone
who I really want to talk to which was
the case sometimes you know I will come
back there was one place that I went
back you know I think three or four
times and finally sort of engaged them
in conversation when those sort of
foot-in-the-door conversations for like
20 or 30 minutes but at the same time
you know if someone really doesn't want
to participate in the story and in this
case I had a spreadsheet of a thousand
you know eleven hundred and sixty two
locations that that you know got these
nuisance abatement actions you know if
they really don't want to participate in
this story then I'll just look for
people that do want to participate in
the story and you know there were some
people that want to you know that we're
willing to talk to me but didn't want to
use their names but I tended to you know
gravitate towards or use the you know
the people in the story that did allow
us to use their names and allowed us to
photograph them and so I think it's a
different circumstance different depends
on your circumstances if it's like one
you know case that you're focusing on
where you don't have eleven hundred and
sixty two I guess I would say that I
would you know go back you know
several times you know I've even like
written letters and or emails I'm sort
of explaining you know what I what I am
trying to do or you can also talk to
other people that are involved in that
incident so but I also just think it
depends on sort of who you're writing
about you know if it's someone who sort
of been victimized and they really don't
want to you know be part of a news
article then at some point you just have
to sort of respect that and you know not
force them to go through that
questions yes please come up to the
microphone yeah an event where he went
to the door you got information she like
checked it and then it seems like maybe
there was something not so true in any
case where you had some contradictory or
seemingly suspect information how did
you proceed from that point to the point
of okay now I know what's true yeah that
did happen a lot honestly I think you
know when you're going to the summe
you're specifically talking about you
know people that I interviewed that had
been you know so I think one thing to
sort of say at the outset you know for
me I personally don't really like
criminal justice stories that try and
you know build a whole issue around a
story of like one infallible person when
it's an issue that affects a lot of
people I think that you know there
weren't any sort of perfect cases in
this and this reporting where you had a
family that had never you know they had
never been touched by drugs and in any
way for if you're talking specifically
about the residential cases and out the
business cases but I think that when you
have like III like real cases and you
know even if you know like Jimmy Lera
Boz her two sons did have run-ins with
the police but I think that and I think
everybody in the residential piece did
have some sort of interaction with with
drugs and sometimes those people you
know the people didn't tell me that like
right off the bat but it was something
that I found through records you know
including actually Jamel Shabazz I had
to dig you know pretty deep and you
kind of came up with those records about
her son's interactions with the police
but I think that that for me gave a
story more credibility because I think
that you know people know that
situations are complex but even more
importantly it forced people to ask the
sort of a essential question of you know
is this right is do we want to say that
taking an entire family out of their
home is a reasonable penalty for someone
who was you know found to have a small
amount of drugs in their home you know
of course it's not a reasonable penalty
the the penalty that the face and in the
civil course is far more severe than
anything that they would face in the
criminal courts for that same offense
and obviously it's not a penalty that
people and you know wealthier white
neighborhoods are facing for those same
offenses and so I think that you know it
doesn't really when I come across what
some people might think of as medicating
details I don't necessarily think that
that's a bad thing I feel like it just
gives the story a little bit more depth
because going into the piece it wasn't
like I don't like heard about people
that were innocent that were you know
suffering these penalties I just felt
that it was it was wrong you know yes
you just upon this a little bit in your
previous answer but I wanted to ask
about issues regarding race and culture
because in your story you talked a lot
about how this primarily affected people
in minority communities and so figuring
out the details regarding their cultural
background or practices and figuring out
there's been a lot more discussion about
the language or in terms of sensitivity
and how these are described especially
if you're unfamiliar with it and when
you had this many cases I would really
like to hear more about the discussions
you had maybe with editors or your
researchers about what to include or
what came up even when you were talking
with in in your views about you know how
much do you explain when it comes to
like you know what are the key details
when it came to things like white powder
and
the apartments uh what what do you mean
I'm sorry in term of it seems like a
multi-part question but in terms of how
what information did we include in the
in each sort of vignette about the
individual and and how their culture
their ethnicity determined what we
included sorry for the confusion may I
mean is so when it comes to a topic that
deals with minority communities sort of
like there there has been criticism
sometimes about when reporters aren't
sensitive to like how they're portrayed
when it comes to crime stories and your
story was very careful in terms of like
explaining the background in terms of
like cultural practice or in terms of
even biographical details and I want to
know if you had discussions with editors
or a you know like stories like
unvarnished really had that you know the
researchers same as linear had deep
discussions about how to talk about
cultural practices or or how to avoid
stereotypes in in the presentation of
those narratives um I had to be honest
that we didn't really have conversations
like it sounds like what you're
describing I think that you know Jamel
Shabazz you know the decision to include
the sort of narrative about the Yvonne
powder was very pertinent because that
was very pertinent to the to the case
because the you know the case was based
on this white powder that they claimed
was cocaine and so you know that to me
seemed you know I'm important to sort of
explain you know the background of you
know why why she was using that powder I
I wish I had a better answer for you I
just kind of feel like the way that I
framed
people in this story was just sort of
naturally how I
approach my subjects I don't I really
try not to stereotype people and I also
try not to sort of like impart like my
you know I don't know views on you know
my story or my other people's stories I
just kind of try and like be sort of
honest and like I try not to over
dramatize things to which i think is
where you know sometimes people run into
problems you know when they're trying to
serve like over dramatize a story I just
prefer to sort of keep it like you know
stripped down to sort of like the
essence of the person that I'm writing
about and just kind of be fair and
honest and I I don't know I but we
didn't have like lengthy debates or
anything like that about about you know
what what to include her or what not to
include I mean yeah sorry thank you
Sarah we can take more questions about
Sarah's story and reporting methods
later at the end at the end of the
panel's I'd like not to present our
second award winner which is about the
opioid epidemic that has devastated
local communities all over the country
but nowhere as bad as the depressed arms
of West Virginia the state with the
highest rate of prescription opioid
overdose deaths in the United States
drug wholesalers have flooded West
Virginia with prescription painkillers
but for years the exact number of
opioids sold there has remained unknown
concerns grew as the number of overdose
deaths skyrocketed two years ago Eric
air am i pronouncing your name correctly
hey reporter the Charleston Gazette Mail
in West Virginia set out to discover
what accounted for the flow of opioids
into his book into his poor state eric
has been a state House reporter since
1998 for the Charleston Gazette mail
circulation 37,000 he has covered
education health and business his work
has won several national awards and his
investigative stories have most
spotlight issues in rural West Virginia
on the side air still does an overnight
shift for the cops once a month for this
series air combined shoe-leather
investigative reporting with innovative
storytelling to uncover how drug
wholesalers exploit supply chains and
tells and tell the stories and he tells
the stories of families broken by
painkiller addictions here is how Eric's
story starts follow the pills and you'll
find the overdose deaths the trail of
painkillers leads to West Virginia's
southern coal fields to places like
Kermit population 392 their out-of-state
drug companies ship nearly nine million
highly addictive and potentially lethal
hydrocodone pills for over two years to
a single pharmacy in the Mingo County
town rural and poor Mingo County has the
fourth highest prescription opioid death
rate of any County in the United States
the trail also weaves through my oming
County were shipments of oxycontin have
doubled and the county's overdose death
rate leads the nation 1 mom-and-pop
pharmacy in Oceania receives 600 times
as many oxycodone pills as the Rite Aid
drugstore just eight blocks away Eric
found that in six years drug wholesalers
showered the state with 780 million
hydrocodone and oxycodone pills while
1728 West Virginians fatally overdosed
on those two pain killers the unfettered
shipments amounted to 433 pain pills for
every man woman and child in West
Virginia to do this story The Gazette
Mail obtained previously confidential
drug shipping sales records sent by the
US Drug Enforcement Administration to
West Virginia Attorney General Patrick
Morrissey the records disclosed the
number of pills sold to every pharmacy
in the state and the drug companies
shipments to all 55 counties in West
Virginia between 2007
in 2012 the wholesalers and the lawyers
fought to keep the sales numbers secret
they accused the Gazette Mail off
sticking its coat intrusive journalistic
nose where it didn't belong
ultimately the judge sided with the
newspaper and unsealed most of the court
record most of the records
this made the Gazette male the first
paper in America to obtain confidential
prescription opioid sales data for
specific distributors and pharmacies as
a result readers in West Virginia could
click on their home counties and see the
number of painkillers sold on a per
capita basis as well as the county's
overdose death rates but this is not
just a number story it's all about
people as well this is Mary Katherine
Mullins she's the woman on the right and
the big photo over there who was 50 when
she died of an opioid overdose Mary
Katherine became addicted to painkillers
after a car accident and a dr. Prasad
prescribed oxycontin for her back pain
doctors just kept prescribing pain pills
her family said and before long Mary
Katherine was hooked she lied to cover
her addiction she stole from her brother
she also shot herself in the stomach in
an attempt to end her life she went to
dozens of doctors who gladly gave her
the prescriptions in December 2015 Mary
Katherine Mullins is hunt for pain pills
led her to South Charleston a doctor
there prescribed her oxycontin and an
anti-anxiety medication a pharmacy
filled it two days later she stopped
breathing in her bed her brother Nick
Mullens a madison police officer
responded to the 911
he tried chest compressions but he could
not revive his sister after this story
was published to West Virginia pharmacy
board voted to enforce a law requiring
drug wholesalers to report suspicious
drug orders from pharmacies a southern
West Virginia County also filed a
lawsuit against the country's largest
drug distributor it cited the gazette
males findings
since then seven counties and three
cities have
through the drug companies or announced
plans to sue and attempt to recover
costs caused by the opioid epidemic two
big drug distributors said that a
lawsuit filed by the state of West
Virginia they promised to pay thirty six
million dollars money that would be used
for drug treatment programs for
courageous reporting performing the face
of powerful opposition to expose the
flood of opioids flowing into West West
Virginia Eric I received the 2017
Pulitzer Prize award for Investigative
Reporting congratulations thank you Eric
you faced tremendous opposition while
reporting on this story who are some of
your most powerful opponents and how did
your newspaper respond to them were you
worried that you would not win this
lawsuit and that you know the big power
of these companies would overcome 37,000
circulation newspaper
yeah actually at the time I didn't
really recognize the size of these
companies until kind of late in the game
one of them the drug distributor
McKesson is on the fortune 500 it's
number five the other arm eresource
Bergen is number 12 and Cardinal health
the other is number 15 they're bigger
than Boeing they're bigger than
Microsoft they're just these gigantic
companies which I think shows our
appetite for prescription drugs because
they don't just deliver opioids they
deliver you know blood pressure
medicines that you know a whole gamut of
different medications so we to kind of
set the stage we went to court there was
a lawsuit back in 2012 against the drug
distributors filed by the former
attorney general it was inherited by a
new Attorney General and the the first
the lawsuit complaint was kind of
generic it just said
you know this these drugs are causing
you know massive problems in our state
that kind of thing there wasn't much
detail in it we we found out that the
lawsuit when I was going through the
docket at the courthouse docket for the
particular lawsuit that there had been
an updated complaint in the lawsuit that
was filed under seal and that was just
shocking to me you know you had a state
with the highest drug overdose death
rating in the nation
you know it's caused all sorts of
problems in our save everything and and
it was filed under seal which we were
just really surprised that so what we
did was we filed a motion to intervene
in the case ultimately to try to unseal
it and then to set the stage we went to
this rural courthouse in southern West
Virginia down in the coal fields and you
know we show up with two lawyers who
were we were blessed to have them
because they were working for free for
us they had about thirty five lawyers
from these drug companies who weren't
working for free they each had a like a
Charleston Council and they had a
corporate counsel and then they had
somebody else from New York or DC or
Pittsburgh or Columbus so long story
short we had a lot of back-and-forth we
had multiple hearings at the end of the
day the judge sided with us he was you
know right in the middle of this this
not only handling this lawsuit but he
was in the middle of you know seeing
people go through his drug court and
seeing that you know the issue firsthand
so from there we we got that we got the
lawsuit unsealed and what it had was
these snippets of information about
shipments from drug distributors to
specific pharmacies some of them were
notorious they call them pill mill
pharmacies because they just turn out
tons of prescriptions dispensed and
there'd be like you know 10,000
oxycodone on a Tuesday and then the same
pharmacy would be like 20,000 on a
Wednesday and then 40,000 hydrocodone on
a Friday and these were these were
numbers that should have been almost
50,000 60,000 should have been there
like yearly amount but they were there
daily you know weekly amount so from
there within that document we did write
a story and I kind of threw it in at the
last minute that one was kind of friend
in the last minute for the Pulitzer is
our third entry that was back in May
2016 and from there within that lawsuit
it kept referring to DEA data shows you
know these pills worshipped there
according to DEA data so we filed a
Freedom of Information Act request with
the attorney general's office for the
documents that they used to show these
particular shipments and that was when
we got all of the you mentioned the
first time in apparently in history we
had gotten every pill shipped to
hydrocodone and oxycodone to every
pharmacy and total number of pills
shipped by each distributor to each
County would you have been able to do
this story if you had not gotten that
data no the key the key was that data I
mean there are things that are publicly
available there's Arcas data that the
DEA puts out that it's by zip code
prefix and it's but they I think like in
our state there's like 12 zip code
prefixes and they also list the drug
amounts in grams so it's kind of
confusing no we we had the when I when I
got the data and I had sources that were
you know saying you need to see this you
need to see it but I really didn't
understand what we were gonna get but
when we got it I was just in shock and
and knew this was something really big
and I I try to tell people I mean it's
kind of anybody in this room who would
have been handed what we were handed
would probably have won the Pulitzer was
dropping your door well the thing is it
took actually that story I mean it
started back in July 2013 so it took a
long time to get where we were getting
but once we got what we got and
everything kind of fell into place and
it was you know it was it was it was
numbers that I think the key was that
there was putting a number to the
problem and then also there were numbers
that it was their own it was the drug
distributors own sales data so there was
no denying it or no refuting it this
story was not just about data which was
also about people like Katherine Mullins
here how did you approach the families
of those who died of drug overdoses well
usually the first thing I try to do is
find in this case if I did find a drug
counselor somebody a Recovery Center
they can point you to somebody
we'd actually gone down it was in within
that same family but we went down with
the intention of doing a profile of
another person within that family who
died of a drug overdose and that's
something we learned really quick these
things run in the families you have
mothers and sons and fathers and
daughters and brothers and sisters that
died so this was you know one of those
cases where we went down to about one
overdose in the family and then this
mother walked in and told us about her
daughter and we went from there you
worked as a daily reporter and I was
asking Sara about the resources for the
Daily News but the male Gazette had even
less resources how'd how'd you pull this
off well I think it was a matter of kind
of covering the story for for four years
as
and while doing that writing daily
stories not covered I covered the
legislature so you know two months out
of the year I'm doing exclusively
stories about you know legislation and
and then the rest of the year I kind of
covered state government corruption I
have to cover press conferences I have
to do press releases there's an
expectation that you're going to you
know feed the beast you got to have you
know at least one or two stories a day
but I you know I knew this issue opioids
was such a big issue that I kind of
latched on to it and then I kind of
wrote this sort of a just you know
hundreds of stories I was writing about
you know rogue doctors that over
prescribe I was writing about pain
clinics that were churning out
prescriptions by the millions I was
covering the whole story inside and out
and that's kind of what sort of set the
stage to prepare me to to write you know
kind of pull it all together after a
couple years I'd like to ask our
students now to ask a couple of
questions any questions on the floor oh
yes please come over careful and if
there are others who want to ask
questions could you come closer to the
microphone please hi I'm Erin I had a
question so we read through our program
a bit about the opioid crisis and I'm
wondering what's first of all you know
because it's become such a nationally
covered issue what the media may have
gotten wrong at the national stage about
this how to avoid those mistakes and
then the last is just where's this story
going now you know what hasn't been
covered and what's going which should be
covered in the future sure I don't think
much has been done wrong as a matter of
fact there's been such incredible
reporting by so many different people
you probably read the stories is 60
minutes it was last weekend
Lenny Bernstein and Scott Hyman at the
the Washington Post they've actually
been covering this story for more than a
year also and they've just done
tremendous work I've seen a lot of
feature stories that just blow me away
The New Yorker Margaret Talbot I don't
think I I mean you would think yeah I
mean I would think there'd be something
but I really haven't seen anything
there's been a little bit of sort of
what do you call it the poverty porn the
people outside the state that come in
and they want to see the shoot the
pictures of people lying on the ground
after an overdose trying to be revived
that kind of thing a little bit of
exploitation but nothing nothing huge
what was your other question the oh the
next story probably the treatment
there's so much money in that and
there's all this infighting between the
medication assisted treatment the
suboxone methadone the vivitrol is is a
vivitrol faction they have all got
lobbyists the faith-based groups
Sheila had talked about the the amount
of money that they want in the
settlement they're not giving any of
that to faith-based groups which in West
Virginia is causing a real ruckus and
and they have less I think less success
than the the medication assisted
treatment but I think there's there's
also a bunch of people are realizing
they can make money from this the
treatment and a lot of the guys that
were running the pain clinics are now
running the treatment clinics I mean
these are when I say pain clinics these
are places where you didn't even have
like a well there was a physician but he
wasn't really there and they'd have you
know they were churning out
prescriptions with machines like print
outs with stamped copies and so now
those guys are all gonna switch ago into
the treatment
part because that's where the money is
so I think that's probably the next big
story thank you the story was really
fantastic at just Wednesday it's was
amazing and I'm wondering what was the
reaction that you got from just ordinary
West Virginians who read it well
surprisingly I got most of the reaction
the Brazil ah there was local people but
there were a lot of people our state
people have left the state in droves and
I got I was really surprised at the
number of people who are from born and
raised West Virginia living someplace
else and saying thanks you know we're
putting a spotlight on this issue the
the you know we we had you know the
local reaction we and we had a you know
was nice to see a lot of people in
recovery where we're praising the
article and that was kind of kind of at
the not the last minute but the last
couple days I read the story and I was
like you know this is really darn
depressing I mean and it you know you
can't get around that but I did try to
put you know weaved in the story about
this woman who went through recovery and
now it's counseling other former people
who were addicted and and she one of the
positive things that came out of the
story was that she later had her
sentence or what do they call that when
they commuted yeah she was you know
pardon that's right
sorry she was pardoned and and that kind
of was a a good news story but that was
that was sort of important I think and
it was kind of a last-minute decision to
put gave it gave people hope you know
that there was a path out of that I
mentioned you looked at New Yorker and
Washington Post as some places that had
really good coverage
this and obviously with some background
in West Virginia but where else did you
what else did you read where else did
you look when when trying to get a
handle on like the scope and just what
exactly you would dive into can I just
ask them off to ask questions so we can
move faster and then one answer I would
remind you I remind you what the
questions you remember the word pardon
my question was if you could walk us
through how you approached clinics or
pharmacies that you already happen to
know we're over prescribing or involved
in some kind of wrongdoing
okay yes my cousin were people that were
addicted were they reluctant to talk to
you and how did you overcome that okay
so what where else did you go to when
you were looking at the reporting that
has been done in this topic other
reporting there's been plenty of other
reporting I mean that was the Washington
Post there was another Eli Saslow did a
great feature as well I didn't I mean it
was kind of like after probably in the
last year when I've kind of read most of
the stuff because I was doing it in such
little chunks at the time and it wasn't
this I don't know what the it wasn't
there wasn't this like back in 2013
people then there wasn't this national
media presence it's kind of all come in
the last year so um how did you approach
to over prescribing pharmacies well in
in some weird ways this is gonna be hard
to believe but some of these pain
clinics they would actually call us and
tell us that they were not bad actors
that they were doing the right thing I
mean some of the worst ones some of the
ones that had written prescriptions that
you know 60 or more people had overdose
they'd call us and say you know we're
just trying to help people who have pain
so they were actually pretty open to
talking it's
what about approaching the the addicted
families uh yeah again we didn't you
know it was weird we were trying we were
still writing about pain pills and of
course the the situation now in in
Western in rest of the country has
switched now to it went to heroin
transition to heroin and then to defend
all now and car fentanyl are the are the
biggest killers now that's increased
like tenfold over the last year you know
as long as you had sort of an entree
with a drug counselor or something like
that people people want to tell their
stories they want to help others learn
from from what happened to them thank
you Eric we will come back if you have
more questions for Eric we'll come back
at the end I'd now like to introduce our
next Award winner Daniel Baer Ajala who
is a photojournalist base in Mexico City
he is a native of Sydney Australia he
has visited more than 60 countries
covering history shaping events
including the Iraq and Afghan Wars the
trial of Saddam Hussein Ebola spread in
West Africa for which he won the 2015
Pulitzer for future photography last
year or the year the year yes last year
Daniel went to the Philippines for the
New York Times to chronicle the brutal
anti-drug campaign led by Philippine
president Rodrigo Duterte
his images vividly portrayed the
indiscriminate slaughter of drug
suspects and the tauren human life exact
it by the Philippine government's war on
drugs for over 35 days Daniel documented
57 homicide victims at 41 crime scenes
for drug users and dealers had been
murdered by vigilantes emboldened by the
president's mandate to current code kill
them all he worked closely with Rica
Concepcion a veteran local journalist
and fixer to interview bystanders and
the relatives of victims go to jails and
rehabilitation centers and to accompany
police officers in different
neighborhoods the resulting interactive
piece they are slaughtering us like
animals featured both these images and
the vivid text along with interactive
video from security cameras in a map for
powerful storytelling showing the
callous disregard for human life in the
Philippines brought about by a
government assault and drug dealers and
users Daniel was awarded his second
Pulitzer Prize this one for breaking
news photography congratulations Daniel
and I'd like to invite Daniel to come up
and and share these photographs so I
think we should have a trigger warning
the photographs can be upsetting good
evening everyone
Thank You Sheila it's an honor to be
here tonight and also an honor to be
here on stage which with Sara and Eric
such committed and dedicated journalists
which is sure one of the main reasons
why they were they here tonight this
story came about last year I'd noticed
during rodrigo duterte 'he's campaigning
before he became president that his
rhetoric was extremely controversial
linking drug statistics to crime rates
and he believed that he could run this
campaign and received a popular vote of
over 80% within the first month
based in Mexico City in being covering a
number of different stories over the
year it was just a story that I'd been
you know seeing pop up in Facebook feeds
and also seeing photographs compelling
photographs from Filipino colleagues who
are out there Rafi learners here tonight
and he's speaking tomorrow night during
the Filipino conference and which kind
of sparked concern and it was one of the
stories that I pitched to my editor that
I was curious to go out and cover I was
on the way to do a rotation in in Syria
and I landed in Mexico City on the day
and found out that my visa hadn't come
through and my never had an email from
my editor saying can you please get to
the Philippines as soon as possible I
ended up calling friends in the
Philippines which had done previously
it's a sort of to check in on the
situation find out what's happening in
the first month or two there were an
average of a thousand people a month
that being killed at the hands of the
police and X traditional killing so I
reached out during those 24 hours as I
was kind of like repacking and I'm
heading out to Manila to find out what
the situation was and I was alarmed you
know when they said look it's actually
this is continuing it's not going to be
stopping it's actually probably going to
get worse when you set off on a story
like this sometimes you have the ability
to prepare for a story and sometimes you
don't you find out in 24 hours notice so
I was luckily that one of the one of my
colleagues set me up with an amazing
translator and fixer Rica concepcin
who'd had 30 years of experience working
in television and she'd been covering
the story from the outset as well so
I'll end it and usually when you working
in different parts of the world and
sometimes you have to you know you land
and you hit the ground running and you
have to basically from scratch
find out what the story is and when I
talk about this I refer to we a lot
because this isn't just my work this
isn't these photographs I've taken but
there would not have been possible
without Rica without working with other
other journalists and working with other
photographers so a lot of the times we
work together as the group most of the
killings were happening at night and I
joined a group of dedicated filipino
journalists guys group of guys were that
were called the night crawlers they had
given themselves a name because most of
the killings were happening in at night
the first night I went out with this
group of TV reporters journalists and
photographers the first the first crime
scene that we came across was on a set
of railway tracks and there was a
shootout with police this is what the
police was telling us they had been
issued out with three drug suspects they
had been selling and and apparently
there was like a 20 minute or so gun
battle there was a group of 30 or 40
journalists that night I believe who
were out in TV cameras and and in
reporting and I noticed something about
the bodies or each one of them was in
the same and I'm sure everyone else
noticed as well they're in the same line
in the same position with a gun next to
their hand almost seemingly kind of like
placed so even from the outset something
didn't look right about five minutes
later world we're trying to move around
this scene because it's kind of
stretched out and covered by police tape
and all of a sudden everyone cleared out
there was news of another crime scene
and I remember thinking to myself at
that point how are we gonna find out the
police is telling us this was a shootout
but how we're gonna find out what
actually happened if we're like racing
from one scene to another so literally
from the outset I kind of knew that in
order to find out put all the pieces
together of this puzzle find out who was
doing the killings or why they were
happening when they were happening and
get an understanding of how communities
were being affected that we'd have to
slow down you know we wouldn't be able
to like chase every crime scene and we'd
have to go back to many of these crime
scenes to interview the families and to
find out you know not only the police
side but also the side of the people in
the neighborhoods who were being
affected so we kind of set off and you
know and the unfortunate thing is that
with most of these stories and and
though we came across is they started
with the the crime scenes and then we
could kind of like pick up the pieces
and then go back and investigate and
find out what was what was going on and
that's the only way that we could
actually sort of really understand while
we were also doing this covering the
crime scenes
we were also putting in permission to
visit rehab rehabilitation centers we
were also putting in a request to go out
with the police themselves we were
putting in a request to go to many of
the jails as well which had been over
overcrowded there had been a kind of an
amnesty that president deter take kind
of offered which was you know if you
guys surrender then you will be exempt
from from this war on drugs president
deter day had been very very vocal and
had called for
the death of thousands and millions of
drug addicts he himself said that if he
had enough willis enough time he'd go
and do it himself later when speaking to
a group of business leaders bragged
about when he was the mayor of Davao
City which had been for over twenty
years that he himself had gone out and
killed people to show his police if I
can do it so can you this disturbing
rhetoric we ended up seeing night
tonight there were an average of 20 or
so killings that were happening per day
over 20 and we could only get to a small
amount of these because of the location
Manila during the day the traffic is
insane it's a city of over 4 million
people and it's extremely congested it
can take three hours to traverse like
eight miles or ten miles or so most of
the killings were happening that night
so we were able to kind of like traverse
through we would actually start the
evenings as well grouped together for a
number of reasons at the Manila District
Police Headquarters number of
journalists had different sources within
sometimes within the police within the
coroner's we would get information from
TV or radio as to where the locations of
of these crime scenes and where that
were happening so we would be we would
you know around seven or eight o'clock
we'd kind of did as a group we would go
and have dinner sometimes we'd take
turns in getting coffee because most of
the time we're working all the way
through the night I was getting back to
the hotel room sometimes at 7:00 a.m.
9:00 a.m. and then having to follow
through and then visit families during
the day so it was it was quite a taxing
assignment to say in the least and me
night spent only just over a month then
refuse here has been covering it for the
whole year and as have other journalists
there as well who would start off at the
police station and then we would like
head through the nine and cover the
crime scenes and then follow back up
with the families interviewing them and
finding out exactly what was happening
and what we found out was the police was
saying that it was self-defense
that the the suspects had resisted
arrest none Lebon which is the term and
had fired first certain reports over the
last year from one from Reuters said
that over 90% of cases ended up in
fatalities so people were not being the
suspects were not being arrested they
were literally being systematically
systematically killed and targeted did
enable hoods that were being affected
were also the poorest neighborhoods
across Manila this photograph of Jim GE
crying in anguish and yelling Papa at
her father's coffin Jim boy Belleza Jim
Bowie and his neighbor and friend alvin
on the twenty of September were abducted
and a few hours later their bodies were
found underneath the bridge shot
mutilated and a week after that Alan's
brother danila was also had the same
fate bestowed upon him and he was his
body was dragged and he was taken from
in front of the house and dumped under a
bridge
we during the time of going back and
interviewing we would also try to get
access to to show the impact of that
this war so-called war I mean it really
wasn't a war this was the targeting
of of suspects you know a lot of times
there were mistaken identities as well
and the wrong person was killed but this
was a scene that we came across when we
were family when we were visiting
Alvin's family next door and came and we
had asked permission if we could come
back to spend time with them as they
showed respect with the wake these
people didn't have enough money to pay
for the funeral costs so what that would
do that have wakes in front of their
houses and they would have a gambler
come in and people from the neighborhood
would would come in and you know show
their respect to family but also they
would be there gambling and ten percent
of the winnings would go to the family
so it took this family over three weeks
to get enough money to to race just to
pay the the funeral costs but it was
these are scenes that were happening all
across Manila and actually are still
happening across Manila there are
families that are being torn apart there
are you know statistics of over twelve
thirteen thousand people that have been
killed the hands of police including
extrajudicial killings
in just over a year now we're going up
with police and that would have us on
certain operations but when we were
there
obviously they weren't taking us on the
raids where they were going in killing
this is Edwin Mendoza who was in front
of a 7-eleven in the evening time
and two gunmen on the back of motorbike
got off and approached and and shot him
dead this was happening all over Manila
mostly in the poorest neighborhoods
Tondo and Quezon City and no vatos this
is a heroine story of flawed john cruz
who was home fixing his grandmother's
transistor radio when police rushed in
and stanton the grandmother out and a
few minutes later floor john was killed
in his living room
the police had claimed that he had
resisted arrest and that was the reason
why they had they had killed floor john
during that time there were different
types of killings were happening there
were these official police raids that
they said were official there were also
extra dish extra judicial killings that
were happening with bodies being taped
up their faces taped up in their hands
behind their backs and their bodies
dumped on the side of the roads with
warning signs putting around their neck
saying if you continue then you'll
you'll end up dead this was a scene of
spending time with having spent time
with the diapering family maria couldn't
afford the the burial of the second son
so she went back to the funeral parlor
till to beg to bring the cost down and
during while she was having the
conversation i was able to kind of get
access and and get an understanding of
like of what these what these areas look
like and this was the overflow room so
you had the morgue which was actually
the room inside and to the right which
we weren't allowed to photograph and he
didn't get access this was the the
overflow room
the man with a shirt there is Daniela
this is an example of the the
extrajudicial killings the face is taped
up and these were mainly in around 4 5 8
a.m. in the body that these butter that
these bodies were being dumped with the
sign around the neck and in their hands
behind their back taped up to serve as a
purpose in a warning for others this is
the first time that actually had to
write a story as well so I found out
about a weekend that there wasn't going
to be a journalist kind of coming that I
was going to be reporting with and that
I would be expected to write something
you know something about my accounts
something about so I kind of went with
that in mind I went and recorded audio
recorded video and pretty much did the
reporting that I would usually do but
actually to spend more time going back
interviewing families to find out to
find out the full story and this scene
was about two and a half weeks in and
this is kind of like I'd been collecting
all this information you know over over
the first few weeks and I just didn't
know you know what would spark off the
story and and and how it would start and
it was just it was so complex and there
was so many things at play and it was
this scene that literally sparked me to
sit down and write everything and it was
getting to a scene one night and
actually not being there as the police
were taking the body away but being
there walking down his dark alleyway and
hearing the screams of Nellie Diaz
weeping for her husband Chrysostom oh
that Chrysostom I had been sleeping with
four of his nine children in in his
apartment and late one night three
gunmen kicked down the door
I'm wearing a motorcycle helmet and shot
him dead in front of the kids and then
left laughing and one of them said
goodbye my friend it was important to
find out inning to view all of these
people and to find to do the story
justice and to find out what the true
story was or find out at least the story
of how the communities were being
affected we were getting the reports
from the police we actually went and
nearly collected close to there were 43
crime scenes I think we ended up getting
like 36 of the police reports because
some of them were actually difficult to
get to them balanced up to to find out
what the police was stating had happened
and nearly in all cases the stories were
completely different
Erika Fernandez was 17 and her boyfriend
was shot one of the things we found out
there was an amazing journalist Patricia
Evangelista who did a story specific
story on on this couple and found out
that most likely they were killed by an
ex-lover so this during this whole time
there was almost a social breakdown I
mean if if you wanted to get rid of a
killer rival or anything like this was
the time to do it because a lot of the
cases weren't being followed up and this
was one of the main floors and and this
seemingly there was a once again a plot
put around the boyfriends Nick and
producer the journalist noticed that
there was something more emotive in the
the writing and she went and interviewed
families but basically found out that
most likely it was it was the xx lover
of Erika's that had that had killed them
both on the street is out walking home
one
after after a restaurant so this this
drug war there are so many people's that
are dead or else that are caught in the
crossfire and innocently killed as well
under the pretense of drugs
thank you I'll leave it to thank you
thank you Daniel tell you you've covered
other wars and other drug wars before
you live in Mexico how is the Philippine
drug quite different from others you've
seen elsewhere it was it was different
in a way that usually it's only recently
I've been covering Mexico but what I
found was that this was something
completely different to anything I'd
ever cover it was literally state
sanctioned campaign of killing on on a
huge level and just the the ferocity and
the speed that it was happening and with
the body count of at least when when I
was there and speaking with Rafi today
there have been ups and downs but it is
it is the keep the killings are still
continuing and this is a year on over a
year on in and what is amazing is that
there's there has been a decrease in
popularity with the president but this
is something that some of the population
actually still do believe that the
president is doing a good job because
he's you know reading the communities of
you know drug dealers of suspects the
thing is that there is no due process
there is no diligence none of the cases
are being investigated hardly any of
them being investigated and it's just
continuing and that's that seems to be
like the main
one question I'd like to ask because our
students here have done or will do
stories that are related to bloodletting
and and you as a photographer are closer
to that than say a print a print
journalist you and you were doing this
for 35 days straight right how how are
you keeping you no sane emits all of
that and then how do you take care of
yourself after it um how do I keep
saying alcohol medication is very very
helpful the times having good friends
who have gone through similar things and
being able to talk about these
situations having colleagues working
with incredible dedicated colleagues
like Rafi who's at the back and gonna be
speaking tomorrow night at the
Philippine conference which is down the
end of the halt tomorrow evening we
would get together as groups of
journalists on a Saturday night and we
would we would we would talk about we
would talk about what we had covered
that day that night that week and that
is one way of of certainly working out
everything because everything we see it
sticks with us you know in some way or
another it works its way through our
psyche bodies and it was you know I mean
we I get to leave
you know I covered for a month and Rafi
and Dandi and and color petrucha and and
like 30 40 other incredible journals so
they're covering it at different times
day in day out and what I like what I
focus on is like we get to leave you
know and it's the families that lives
have been have been affected and changed
forever and
and the journalists who are also
covering it so I try to keep that in a
perspective and I also you know what
keeps me going is use the feeling of
good we have a responsibility we have a
responsibility to be covering these
stories and this was a story that had
certainly been reported in the news but
it really for some reason you know with
the with the numbers with everything
happening and it was compelling what
coming out there are many many people
who still didn't know about what was
happening in the Philippines at times so
you know when you when you come back and
you've you've done you know you've
pulled an all-nighter just like 7:00
a.m. 9:00 a.m. I mean we're getting
breakfast which is out dinner or
whatever and getting two three hours
sleep in the back of my mind I'm
thinking if I'm not out there there are
stories that are being that aren't being
covered and now I'm being told
also when you're there you never know I
never know how long I'm going to be on
assignment whether I'm gonna be pulled
out after the first week or the second
week or even the third week and I'm in
close contact with my editor a while I'm
out on assignment as well and we're
trying to work out in terms of my kind
of like fatigue levels which he kind of
at the end of this about three and a
half or four weeks in he said okay
you've got there's so much material
we're not gonna be able to publish any
but you need to now write and I would
sit in my hotel room and I was like just
had fries a writer's block and I'm not a
writer I'm so much respect what you guys
do and so I would like trying to be
piecing together and putting sense of
everything that would come across and I
would still be going out at night and my
editor would call me up the next day and
go oh so how'd you go with the writing I
was like uh kind of didn't get around to
it cuz I kind of went out again last
night and he's like - do not go out I'm
ordering you like not to go out you need
to write
so having someone who is conscious also
of because you get so involved in the
story and Rafi knows as well that that
you just you you there is this
compulsion and this responsibility just
to keep on going and you would probably
like work ourselves into the ground if
we if we if we kept on doing that but
one thing a close friend colleague once
told me to knocked away which was these
people have a right to have this story
told and there are so many stories that
you know go down as a statistic go down
as a police operation and we've actually
talked about this a lot as in our role
like what are we doing and because three
weeks in when you're covering this
day-in day-out crime scene you just you
you've you've felt I felt so like futile
though that the work wasn't being that
hadn't been published yet and it was it
was like this is still going on and
we're powerless no no we're not like
Superman and we can stop this but it
there was this kind of weird sort of
connection there like you know the work
isn't having any effect now and we're
literally just like covering it and one
thing we kind of like talked about was
the importance to keep on going and the
importance that regardless of whether
the the photos are being published or
not if we went there as journalists
covering this story we would look back
at this time in history 20 years later
or 25 years later and if it was up to
the hands of of the president and the
campaign they would look back and go
like you know what they did a great
amazing job they apprehended these many
suspects and these many people who
resisted arrest and they killed them all
and what we're doing is is recording the
voices of these families that didn't
have the opportunity to have their
stories told because it's just so
widespread so we we often talked about
when we kind of like got bummed out and
exhausted it's like we have to keep on
going because we're like we're gathering
evidence of what is of what is happening
and and giving the other version I'd
like to invite those who have questions
either for Daniel or for the other
panelists to please come up the mic
while I ask another question of Daniel
which is your editorial choices since
you said you had so much material how
did you win oh that Dan and what did you
decide how did you decide which were the
most powerful pictures do I think I
photographed over that period of time
$25 or 25,000 images and I week-to-week
was filing photos to my editor just so
he knew what I had and and how we could
grow the story and what parts were kind
of were missing in order of getting like
a greater understanding of the situation
there so I ended up I think the the
large the wide edit that I sent him was
around 800 images which he then said
okay I want these 320 captioned color
corrected and everything and then that's
what I sent in then based on that that
was whittled down to around 80 and this
was done when I went back to Mexico City
at the end of the month I was also
editing day to day so I was getting back
from the evenings 6 7 a.m. and I was
like downloading my cards and most nice
it was like falling asleep with my
laptop on my chest halfway through an
edit just to know what I had and what
I'd missed and and how to grow the story
and and how to take it forward
so David kind of took over that that
whole sort of editing process and on top
of that there were so many people who
were brought in during the month that I
was there I was taking down
I was geo-tagging all of the locations I
don't know what I would be using the
information for I've used it in the past
on assignments in remote Pakistan to
find a village again and have to
returned a year later to follow up with
certain families so I didn't exactly
know in what way they would be able to
use that information but I was just
trying to gather as much data as
possible and we end
up doing a interactive and and also Rika
was working hard to get access to CCTV
footage that would had been taken and
that had showed contradictory evidence
of what the police were saying so there
were there was a whole group of people
at the at the newspaper and it was it
took like about a month to publish and
David my editor was campaigning hard
with the great team of graphics with a
team that was doing the translations as
well because it was translated into a
number of different languages tagalog
filipino was was was one of them and so
while he was doing that the editing and
I think there were around 22 pictures
which made the the digital presentation
and then he also had a layout he was
doing the layouts in the newspaper which
ran in the front page and the double
spread on inside so there was there's a
large kind of group of people that were
also working on this to maximize the
story but it was it was my editor that
that ended up kind of like choosing the
final selection there was some sort of
say but that point I was so exhausted of
like looking at the photographs that I
really wanted him to kind of like take
over and and drive it your question
please yes thank you so much for sharing
the photographs I was wondering when you
were working with like a really big
group of journalists it sounded like
kind of all went in a pack together
what's that helpful to you did a was it
done because it was a little safer that
way
or was it more of a hindrance because
there's just so many people and they're
all trying to get to the story
absolutely that's a good question
sometimes it was it was a help and
sometimes it was it was a hindrance but
most of the times it was it was helped
because we were all there and everyone
worked together as a team in a way
everyone like shared information that
was your and then the nights and then
during the day we would you know as
as um photographing Rico is interviewing
people at the scene gathering as much
information she was also gathering and
doing videos so we were able to go back
and get quotes from specific families
and then we're going back through the
families on our own so it will break off
from the group during some times during
the night sometimes during the during
the day and go and find and and focus on
stories that we thought were were
important and interviewing attending
wakes attending funerals and then also
on top of that having sort of meetings
to get access as well so it was at less
more it was less safety in numbers
things because in some way at the start
of this the police were proud of what
they were doing they felt like that that
were like showing us the great work that
they'd been doing and apprehending and
and neutralizing was one term that they
like - neutralizing suspects so you know
in other stories I've covered you there
is that certain safety in numbers but
this was it was also something that was
going on every single day so there were
there were times a lot of the guys some
of them work for newspapers and they
were on shift so you know Monday night
there'd be a large crowd of people
because they've taken the weekend off so
it was it was completely varied
sometimes we turned up to crime scenes
and we were the only people that were
there so it was it was a it was a real
mix who wanted needed you to report
their stories did you meet with
hostility from people that supported
what was happening
we're glad and resented your
in in those communities where this was
happening we didn't have that it was
only in conversations that we'd have
with a taxi driver people outside of our
sphere and who were outside of what was
gone because what was amazing is that a
large percent of the population didn't
know this was happening in their own
town you know and with a huge town a
city of four million people you know if
this happens in some of the poorest
communities and it's spaced-out the
media also there were times when Raffi
worked on day after day for three weeks
three weeks or so they hadn't published
his work so because for various reasons
there were papers that were Pro today
there were papers that were balanced and
some that some that weren't so it was
really interesting to find out that a
lot of people didn't know this was going
on and when you know in those
communities people absolutely you know
we would have a crowd of people who
would be like yeah and they came a group
of eight masked men came across the
railway tracks and grabbed Jamar Keough
when he was playing with his 13 year old
nephew real well they were playing video
games and they just grabbed him dragged
him down an alleyway handcuffed him and
then shot him shot him dead told all the
residents screamed at them to go back
into their houses and then shot him you
know cold-called been in in an alleyway
and then claimed that you know while he
was in handcuffs he somehow pulled out a
gun and the gun was there and they
miraculously pulled out a small little
sachet of Osia boo-boo and most of the
crime scenes were like cut and paste
like copy and paste like and we it was
it was a sick joke but it was like
nearly every scene had a 38 caliber
handgun so were like man is probably the
same handgun that's being like just like
turned over but yeah once in those
communities people were very vocal
because this the this is a police
station which is across the
the side of the tracks these are people
these are police officer that they not
that are doing this within their
communities you know there's another
story which published Rico was working
on I think it published a week or two
weeks ago that the barangay leaders the
leaders in these communities are giving
lists of people to the police of
supposed suspects and and the people
that make this list who knows whether
the users are not users none of them get
a chance to have their voices heard and
then the police or vigilantes or
whatever go in and execute so during the
day we would hear you know we would and
you you know you would see the support
around town for deter a and then when
you go to these neighborhoods so the
shift is happening but it's happening
slowly and early on people were afraid
to speak out from these neighborhoods
are really really afraid to speak out
and now there's a wave there's a
movement and more people are protesting
more people are reporting on it and more
people who have a confidence to speak
out because at the start they were
afraid they were really really afraid
you had a question and I'd like to
invite the other if there questions for
the other panelists please come up as
well yes Danny so your photograph you
you also photographing the the family of
the people who were shot and they were
victims and they were in great distress
so have you ever been taken back and say
oh you can I can I can't shoot this yeah
a respect for the victims it happens a
lot we for me the working respectfully
is the most important thing if people
don't want me there
I won't photograph so I only photograph
in places I mean especially intimate
moments with Jimmy G when we've been
there when we've spent time with the
families and we build up trust with them
and they know our intentions they know
why we're there were there to tell their
stories and you know I there's no there
was actually not in on this the Simon
I'm just thinking of there are times
when people say no no no stop it was
time in Nepal when I was photographing a
funeral scene on the side of a mountain
and an epicenter of Babak and those
family members there that really didn't
understand well with it and started sort
of screaming and I was there with
another colleague and we very calmly
very quietly got the opportunity to talk
with them again we had permission from
the rest of the family we mentioned to
them that if we weren't there taking
these photographs that there is no way
that other people in the rest of the
world would know about what is happening
in their village and sometimes we have
to you know like explain why we're there
and there when it comes to you know
emotional challenges or challenges of
covering things like they're serving so
many times they're like I've been
overcome by emotion and I haven't been
able to photograph and what I you know
I've caught myself during those times
after the fact a few minutes later and
I'm like look I'm not a medic I am NOT
an NGO worker and if I'm not doing my
job like what why am I here you know so
I try to have that in the back of my
mind sometimes I'm successful some
sometimes I'm not successful but that's
something that you do to kind of like
override and when you're there in the
moment I'm trying to make sense of
everything I'm making sure that my
photos are in focus that the ISO is
right that the shutter speed is correct
and just doing these little things helps
me you know you know you know in a
strange way to kind of focus on what's
happening there but I something that I
keep on reminding myself that he fine
you know if I'm not there and able to
report during these times like what is
my purpose there you know and that's you
know that's something which you know
sounds great in theory but you know it
changes every every time in every
situation when you think you're being
desensitized or you think that you know
you're getting used to it in a way you
get completely bowled over and and you
know there being so many times in and
during this story as well that I wasn't
able to like for
and it took me a while to kind of
compose myself and to like to keep on
you know and have that dialogue
monologue in the back of my head saying
man you got to keep on going you have to
keep on because it's this is important
you know showing showing the effect on
these families it it you know and and
and knowing the story and and who they
are and how they were affected this is
the way that we're able to reach other
people from across the world and and
hopefully you know make them stop think
and and feel something you know you had
a question
yes changes it Sarah yeah so Sarah the
the they're all fascinating stories but
when I was with the photographs that
it's clear that there's a there's a you
know a boss in charge who doesn't like
drug addicts or pharmaceutical has a
profit motive but I'm doing I'm doing a
little bit of a story right now and and
I'm actually a former enforcement agent
the city from the civil enforcement unit
no no sanitation enforcement I'll take
these people already ticket so I don't
work for them anymore
they fired me but my question is is is
ticket quotas because if it's if it is
if if what you're saying is that that
all top brass it and what a PD is all
it's a racist motive I don't I don't
know I think that it's more of uh it
seems like it is a profit motive in
terms of quota mm-hmm that they target
and I could tell you absolutely true
that target that tark the low-income
rights they don't fight that right yeah
I don't think that i explicitly accused
the the civil enforcement you know
attorneys or the NYPD of their motive
being you know to target people because
they're racist I think that it's as you
said they target well there's there's a
cop
reasons but they target you know certain
areas you know where more people are
less equipped to defend themselves you
know for the residents you know they're
not going to bring a case like that and
you know against a home on the Upper
East Side because they've barely stand
up in court
and most of the residential tenants you
know didn't have attorneys only nine
percent actually had legal
representation and it's actually a
pretty complex area of law but I think
that you know one of the things that I I
tried to show in the piece that
specifically both focused focused rather
on the civil enforcement unit it all
sort of ties in with broken windows and
and broken windows sort of marriage with
ComStat which made broken windows
policing very numbers driven so nuisance
abatement wasn't you know talked about
as much as you know summonses or you
know stop and frisk or marijuana arrests
but you know Bratton had called it the
most powerful civil tool available in
broken windows so what was explained to
me is you know you have you know
particular areas that yeah and sometimes
actually you know and I think that this
was in my and the business piece like
that they aren't necessarily
particularly high in crime but when they
go to you know concept meetings they'll
say like what are you doing about you
know this issue and one of the things
that they show as a form of proactive
policing is that they're you know making
summonses they're making stops they're
filing nuisance abatement actions so you
know that's sort of one you know aspect
of it the attorneys at the civil
enforcement unit who I spoke to so that
they were under a lot of pressure to
meet sort of a certain number of cases a
week even as crime went down they did
have a financial motive because they did
receive a lot of overtime which I
reported on for filing these cases a lot
of times you know particularly because
they would serve the cases at night at
11 o'clock at night after after work
hours and so that's hundreds of dollars
in their pocket every time they serve
one of these cases
you know one of the detectives that
filed that you know brought nuisance
abatement cases are pieced together
nuisance abatement cases and underage
alcohol alcohol sales against you know
pretty much like every bodega in East
Harlem then was promoted to Detective
you know sort of demonstrating you know
proactive policing we didn't talk so
much about the business cases but I
think that it's just as important as the
residential cases because a lot of times
these are small business owners who have
their life savings in their business and
and you know a lot of homes they they
lost the business as a result of the
nuisance pavement action and in that
case you know a lot of the business
owners that we approached did not speak
English and that's where the
photographer who I was reporting with
Edwin Torres is really important because
a lot of those business owners spoke
Spanish so they didn't even even though
they had businesses tended to have
representation
you know I explained the settlements to
a lot of people and including the ones
who had attorneys well through--through
Edwin because the attorneys hadn't sort
of fully explained to them the various
repercussions that they could face for
XY and Z or the full terms of their
settlements so I think that they're you
know it's definitely some sort of like
preying on people who you know are less
have less resources to defend themselves
in in a case like this a lot of people
conflated the nuisance abatement case
with a criminal case you know and you
know so that so had to be teased out but
you can just if that helps sort of
understand just like how you know
confusing this process is a lot of
people thought that the NYPD's attorney
was that a court-appointed attorney they
didn't know that they didn't get a
court-appointed attorney in civil court
so but yeah I mean I think that in terms
of motive I never I mean I think that
the you know part of the motive that I
probably advanced the most was the sort
of more numbers driven you know broken
windows policing over time you know type
motive so but but I think it's important
to note that
are always targeting places that are in
black and Hispanic communities but thank
you Sarah I think we need to bring this
I know you have an appointment we need
to bring this seminar to a close thank
you everyone for staying to the end of
it and congratulations again for the
Pulitzer Prize awardees
[Music]